am Donnerstag findet in der
Schwarzenbergkaserne in Salzburg die
Übergabe der Kommandoführung des
Militärkommandos Salzburg Stadt nach
über 4 Jahrzehnten tritt der scheidende
Kommandant Brigadier Anton Waldner den
wohlverdienten Ruhestand an von Salzburg
Landeshauptmann Wilfried Haslauer wird
Waldner mit dem großen Ehrenzeichen des
Landes Salzburg für seine zahllosen
Verdienste ausgezeichnet
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
würdigt vor allem waldners Engagement
danke Ihnen für dieses Engagement für
die umsichtige Führung des
Militärkommandos aber überhaupt für all
ihre Leistungen ihr großes Engagement
das in diesen vergangenen Jahrzehnten in
den 43 Jahren für das österreichische
Bundesheer gezeigt haben
51-Jährige Peter Schinnerl er wird den
erfolgreichen Weg weitergehen und die
Stärkung Salzburg als zentraler Standort
des Bundesheeres vorantreiben
alle Erfahrungen die du gemacht hast die
militärischen und im zivilen Bereich in
dieser neuen Funktion
führe dieses Militärkommando Salzburg
mit großer Umsicht und mit Engagement
[Applaus]